[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
Bienvenue c'est sens public 90 minutes
de débats et de reportage comme tous les
soirs on donne du sens à l'actualité on
vous propose des clés de compréhension
des mutations de notre société grâce à
nos invités experts regain de
mobilisation et de tension pour la 9e
journée de mobilisation contre la
réforme des retraites le 49-3 vers
rebooster les opposants et l'interview
télé d'Emmanuel Macron ne les a pas
calmés bien au contraire avec des
affrontements qui se multiplient la
question de violence policière
illégitime se pose de nouveau comme à
l'époque des gilets jaunes ce sera l'un
des angles de notre premier débat et
puis en 45 minutes on prend du recul sur
l'actualité avec un débat de société sur
les nouvelles dérives sectaires souvent
liées à la santé à de pseudothérapie
ça fait un moment qu'on est rentré dans
l'air des dérives de santé parce que
elle fleurissent de partout parce que
n'importe qui vu qu'il y a pas de cadre
non plus vraiment légal de toutes ces
formations et de tous ces
prétentions de thérapie alternatives il
y a des des charlatans et des gourous
qui apparaissent de partout qui sont ces
nouveaux gourous qui pullulent sur
Internet quels sont leurs liens avec le
complotisme les moyens de l'État et de
la justice sont-ils adaptés réponse tout
à l'heure mais d'abord les Français qui
refusent de travailler jusqu'à 64 ans
battait le pavé toujours plus remonté
contre l'exécutif cet artage au cœur de
la manif parisienne avec Jonathan
Dupriez et Adrien pain
la colère de la rue ne sait pas apaisée
en témoigne ce cortège parisien très
dense entre Bastille et opéra 800.000
manifestants selon la CGT au lendemain
de l'intervention télévisée d'Emmanuel
Macron l'Inter syndical est toujours en
ordre de bataille plus soudé que jamais
et réclame toujours le retrait pur et
simple de la réforme l'objectif c'est de
montrer que la détermination et la
colère elle est encore elle est toujours
aussi importante voire plus je pense
qu'elle n'est plus d'ailleurs et donc
l'objectif c'est toujours la même chose
retirer votre projet mais les syndicats
ont surtout témoigné de l'agacement face
à un président de la République source
selon eux ou revendications qu'il porte
Laurent Berger notamment critiqué par le
chef de l'État pour n'avoir pas su
trouver des compromis a tenu à lui
répondre en tête de cortège c'est que ça
se fait pas quoi et puis avec le plus
important c'est pas ça je suis prêt à
vraiment tout oublier sur les mots qui
ont été prononcés hier si le président
de la République mets pause et retire et
retire ce projet
je promets que j'aurai tout oublié
dans le cortège les manifestants semble
porter par un nouvel élan persuadé que
le conflit n'est pas terminé malgré le
passage en force de la réforme
9 3 parce qu'on avait déjà une loi qui
était très brutale mais alors le médium
pour le faire passer et d'une autre
brutalité encore c'est un déni quelque
part et je ne pense pas qu'on peut
diriger une puissance la cinquième
puissance mondiale par du déni et par
l'ignorance des aspirations profondes du
peuple aux côtés des Parisiens des
parlementaires de gauche se sont joint
la mobilisation tout sont les yeux rivés
vers les recours déposés auprès du
Conseil constitutionnel pour censurer
tout ou partie de ce projet de loi
ecoutez de dire pendant
du texte les exigences de sincérité de
clarté que veulent n'était pas respecté
le fait qu'ils aient voulu accumuler
toutes les procédures pour enjamber les
votes du Parlement aujourd'hui j'ai
confiance dans le fait que le Conseil
devrait en principe à porter aux
Français la réponse qu'ils attendent
puisque le président de la République
n'est pas capable de le faire lui-même
et puis c'est pas complètement terminé
parce que on a également avec l'ensemble
des parlementaires de gauche permis un
référendum d'initiative partagée avec le
Conseil constitutionnel doit valider
alors que le gouvernement reste campé
sur ses positions l'Inter syndical croit
encore pouvoir faire plier l'exécutif et
devrait décider dans la soirée de
poursuivre son bras de fer dans la rue
est-ce que le mouvement est en train de
changer de nature voilà une des
questions que je vais poser à mes
invités Sophie dravinel bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes grand reporté au
service politique du Figaro et vous
suiviez pour pour Le Figaro la
manifestation parisienne auprès des
politiques aujourd'hui vous ne
connaissent bonsoir bienvenue
politologue chercheur ocnrs et aux
accueille bonsoir bienvenue à vous vous
êtes professeur de sciences politiques à
Sciences Po Saint-Germain-en-Laye et
auteur avec Nathalie du Clos de
l'ouvrage violence politique qui est
parue chez Armand Colin et Mathilde
Sirault bonsoir Mathis politique à mes
côtés comme chaque jeudi 1er conseil je
démarre avec vous Sophie dravinel et les
incidents parfois les violences dans
plusieurs manifestations en province à
Paris
la question que je posais en ouverture
est-ce que vous pensez que le mouvement
est un peu en train de changer de nature
oui forcément depuis jeudi dernier il y
a quelque chose qui a changé on le sent
dans la rue j'ai suivi quelques huit
autres cortèges précédents à Paris ce
qui est différent
de des autres villes en France mais qui
quand même reflètent un petit peu
l'atmosphère et on sentait aujourd'hui
évidemment depuis jeudi dernier encore
plus depuis l'interview hier du chef de
l'État un changement d'état d'esprit une
forme de tension le côté bonne enfant
dans le cortège familial n'est pas
absent il est toujours bien là on sent
toujours des foules très familiales très
très décidées très déterminé un petit
peu j'allais dire à l'image de l'opinion
publique française finalement qui pour
l'instant n'a pas bougé qui reste
stablement de façon stable opposée à
cette réforme et qui ne comprend pas de
sens depuis le début on sentait
cependant donc cette violence n'était
pas que dans les écritos qu'on a pu lire
elle était clairement dans le cortège et
clairement on sentait que aussi bien les
services d'ordre des syndicats que
ceux des politiques et même la foule
l'essai plus libre cours auparavant
cette violence de s'exprimer alors ça
c'est intéressant Bruno cotress les
syndicats avaient mis en garde Emmanuel
Macron sur les conséquences d'un 49-3
est-ce que pour autant alors on peut
dire qu'ils sont quoi un peu débordés ce
soir il l'avait anticipé comme quand
vous l'analysez ça qu'est-ce qui est
clair c'est que toutes les données de
pignons dont on dispose montrent
qu'effectivement
l'opinion était dans une très forte
attente vis-à-vis de la parole du chef
de l'État avec l'idée qu'il allait
peut-être annoncer une manière
d'accommoder la situation peut-être pas
un recul et c'est vrai que les premières
enquêtes qui ont été réalisées qui
montrent que 70% des personnes ont
trouvé qu'il n'était pas convaincants
montrent que l'exercice n'a pas été
réussi et c'est vrai que de ce produit
là il y a un énorme enjeu à la fois
politique
civique qui touche aussi à la à la
situation et à la bonne bon déroulement
de ce qui va se ce qui va se passer il y
a un énorme enjeu on a vu que tout au
long de cette crise les syndicats à la
différence de la crise des gilets jaunes
était fortement présent qui jouait leur
rôle de médiation politique de donner
une perspective de donner des directions
de d'encadrer un petit peu le sentiment
que cette réforme légende de s'y
retrouver pas donc ça c'est un point
absolument central de notre démocratie
sociale et c'est vrai que il faut
conserver le plus possible cette idée
que les syndicats se sont eux qui sont
naturellement les principaux concernés
organisateurs de mobilisation alors
après on voit que le chef d'État
zigzaguer au cours de sa prise de parole
qu'il a un petit peu joué avec certaines
lignes faisant le distinguo entre les
manifestations encadrées par les
syndicats et puisqu'il appelé la foule
les factions etc et de ce point de là
c'est vrai que du simple point de vue de
l'analyse politique qu'il a il a il a
joué avec un petit peu avec les lignes
et on y reviendra évidemment il y a un
mot qui vient ces mots frustration sa
vie chrétien est-ce que peut-être que
cette violence qui commence à s'exprimer
d'une façon un peu plus générale en tout
cas je suis prud sur les mots que
j'emploie mais est-ce qu'elle vient pas
de la frustration de huit journées de
manifestations ou de mobilisation
précédente finalement on va servi à
grand chose en tout cas pas bloquer le
projet oui c'est vrai mais je pense pas
que ça soit l'élément majeur parce qu'il
y a eu beaucoup de cas où il y a eu des
manifestations successives sans que
finalement ça aboutisse automatiquement
mais par contre vous avez raison de
parler de frustration mais je pense que
c'est particulièrement lié en effet à
l'usage du 49.3 faut bien voir que à mon
sens et le président a mis en opposition
de légitimité la légitimité
institutionnelle et la légitimité de la
rue en déniant à cette dernière en toute
forme de légitimité la rue n'a pas de
légitimité parce que seuls les
institutions en ont ce qui est un
discours finalement qui est tout à fait
républicain et qui peut se comprendre le
seul problème c'est qu'il y a
contradiction lorsque on dit finalement
je vais faire passer un texte sans
passer par la légitimité
institutionnelle en allant au vote
bloqué en utilisant 49.3 en faisant un
passage en force donc là évidemment il y
a une incompréhension complète si la rue
a pas de légitimité et seul le Parlement
en a et ben dans ce cas là que le
Parlement vote le texte si on passe
outre le vote du texte ça veut dire
finalement en tout cas du point de vue
de la rue qu'on peut retrouver une forme
de légitimité c'est quoi il y a c'est
une forme de tout était légal mais il y
a une forme de violence institutionnelle
en quelque sorte en tout cas ressenti
comme tel exactement et vous avez raison
d'utiliser ce terme parce que par
ailleurs ça offre dès lors une forme de
justification très forte aux
manifestants quand on fait de la
violence politique ce qui caractérise la
violence politique par rapport à
d'autres formes de violence c'est
qu'elle doit être justifiée on fait de
la violence au nom d'une cause au nom
d'une idéologie d'une doctrine ou d'une
éthique etc et là évidemment
ça offre d'une certaine façon aux
manifestants et aux manifestants
violents un registre de justification
nous ne sommes pas violents nous ne
faisons que répondre à une violence
institutionnelle qui nous a précédé donc
la violence n'est que réponse et du coup
elle est considérée comme légitime par
ce qu'il a pratique mais alors si on se
place Sophie davinel du côté des 30% de
Français qui continuent de soutenir la
réforme le discours des mêmes Macron qui
quand même consistait à justifier le
49-3 par
d'urgence le sens des responsabilités
l'obligation de faire cette réforme ces
arguments il pèsent aussi absolument et
c'est d'ailleurs assez 30% qu'il s'est
adressé hier au journal de 13h c'est
bien à ces personnes là qu'il a parlé
donc à sa base à ceux sur laquelle à
cette base sur laquelle il compte
aujourd'hui pour essayer de reconquérir
l'opinion publique et ça va être une
œuvre compliquée mais de fait c'est
surtout là on parle de violence du côté
de ceux qui sont opposés du côté qui
ceux qui soutiennent la réforme c'est sa
détermination et c'est une détermination
qu'il salue et dont ils sont extrêmement
satisfaits face à la foule et face au
casseurs et donc ces casseurs c'est bien
aussi cela que joue le chef de l'État
parce que il cherche à à faire basculer
cette opinion politique au moins une
partie d'entre elles et il peut le faire
en montrant qu'effectivement il y a un
risque de chaos parce que les français
malgré tout restent très attachés à
l'ordre et donc et d'ailleurs c'est ce
que lui c'est ce dont l'accuse la
nupaisse c'est à dire toute cette gauche
écologiste Insou c'est de vouloir jouer
le chaos pour faire basculer l'opinion
publique et apparaître comme le parti de
l'ordre alors on va rester sur ce thème
là je vais vous donner la parole
évidemment Bruno là dessus mais puisque
la question finalement du maintien de
l'ordre de la stratégie policière ces
questions qu'on a si souvent abordé
pendant la crise des gilets jaunes elle
revienne sur le devant de la scène et de
l'actualité je vous propose plusieurs
témoignages d'abord celui d'une lycéenne
élève de première au lycée Louis Legrand
à Paris
la répression policière est énorme en ce
moment on la police a jamais été la
police a jamais cherché à faire copain
copain avec les manifestants mais ils
sont de plus en plus en roue libre et
ils sont de plus en plus violents envers
les manifestants ils arrêtent sur 300
arrestations il y a 9 personnes qui sont
déférées il y a c'est des arrestations
inutiles simplement pour faire peur et
il y a un énorme travail de la police
autour du fait de de faire
d'avoir une répression énorme simplement
pour dissuader et pour que les gens
viennent pas en manif et viennent pas en
blocus alors cette lycéenne elle dénonce
notamment les interpellations
préventives je propose d'écouter la du
préfet de police de Paris Laurent Dounia
s'était ce matin sur RTL il y a pas
d'interprétation préventive ça n'existe
pas dans notre pays quand les forces de
l'ordre interpellent les individus c'est
parce que ils ont une suspicion forte
voire ils les ont vu commettre des
infractions alors évidemment on a un
certain nombre de fractions collectives
comme le fait de se constituer en
groupement en vue de commettre des
violences qui est une infraction que
nous avons souvent à mettre en oeuvre
donc évidemment il y a des
interpellations d'individus qui à ce
moment-là sont placés en garde à vue par
un OPJ et dans le temps de la garde à
vue nous essayons de caractériser le
matérialiser cette infraction donc il
n'y a pas les interpellations
préventives ça n'existe pas la brio
Patricia une question qui est centrale
c'est la question de la réponse graduée
ou de la violence poussière légitime
est-ce que on est là dedans est-ce que
les violences qui qui se déroulent
pendant les manifestations en marge et
manifestations légitime la réponse
policière vous avez bien raison c'est à
dire que la question de la légitimité
c'est en toile de fond de la grande
question qui est posé pour rebondir sur
ce qui était dit tout à l'heure
d'ailleurs on voit que l'exécutif est
pris dans cet état de contradiction avec
lui-même il a essayé de rattraper par la
Manche la question de la légitimité on a
nous proposant un drôle d'arguments
selon lequel le défaut d'adoption de la
motion de censure était d'une certaine
manière à votre d'approbation du
législateur donc une sorte de drôle
d'explications
de victoire et on voit qu'en toile de
fond de toute cette crise il y a à la
fois des conflits sur ce que veut dire
la légitimité sur qui est légitime et la
crise parle beaucoup en toile de fond de
cette question et c'est ça qui est
d'ailleurs fait un lien avec les crises
précédentes et alors voilà on a plein de
vraiment le sujet de la violence de la
violence légitime les paroles des jeunes
lycéens qui se situe dans un autre
registre qui est celui de l'émotion
suscité par les images qu'ils ont vu
un certain nombre d'images qui sont
effectivement des images qui font état
de de
on va dire de comportement Pol qui sont
potentiellement voilà de dérapage et
puis on voit de l'autre côté la parole
du préfet de police pourtant se préfet
de police qui est réputé pour son
approche de capacité à gérer
correctement l'ordre public en situation
de manifestation qui justement a été
nommé pour trancher avec le précédent et
on retourne sur des en revient sur des
problématiques qu'on a qu'on a connu
c'est vrai Sophie davinel on a des on
l'a dit lors des premières journées de
mobilisation qu'il y avait une autre
méthode de la police c'est on expliquait
le fait que ça se passe bien par le
service d'ordre des syndicats mais aussi
un changement de méthode de la police et
je l'ai observé en voyais les forces de
l'ordre dans des rues parallèles mais
qui n'étaient pas au contact visuel des
manifestants ce qui compte beaucoup
alors je suis pas spécialiste de police
justice je suis en politique mais en
tout cas nous avons cette
expérimentation du terrain et j'ai pu
observer par rapport à l'époque des
gilets jaunes moi je les suis depuis la
loi travail donc ça fait quand même un
petit moment et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on n'a pas vu tous les sous-titres parce
qu'ils étaient en partie cachés par le
bandeau mais il y a effectivement ces
mots sac à merde qui sont qui sont
employés elle devient un peu
emblématique cette cette vidéo elle
devient emblématique et je pense qu'elle
mérite de l'être parce que on se demande
si on est encore en France quand on voit
ça alors moi ce n'est pas mon habitude
de de faire je voilà mais je pense qu'en
tout cas je représente le français moyen
assez bien et je pense qu'effectivement
elle est très marquante et elle n'est
pas bonne du tout pour l'institution des
forces de l'ordre et donc elle n'est pas
bonne pour déjà l'image de la France
évidemment on a vu depuis plusieurs
jours qu'à l'étranger nombreux sont ceux
qui s'inquiètent justement de ces
manifestations de fin de ces
débordements et je pense que le préfet
Nunez est inquiet lui aussi et il a
répondu sur cette vidéo en l'écoute
encore sur RTL ce matin
concernant les gestes que vous avez cité
évidemment je me défoncerai pas ce sont
des actes qui sont extrêmement
minoritaires pour lesquels en tant que
préfet de police est responsable de mes
hommes et de mes femmes qui s'engagent
sur le terrain je demande
systématiquement des rapports
administratifs pour comprendre le
contexte et ce contexte il est parfois
bien plus compliqué que le simple
visionnage d'une vidéo de quelques
secondes Xavier chrétier je vais pas
chercher d'excuses forcément aux
policiers on est à 8 jours de
manifestation non-stop tous les soirs à
Paris il y a peut-être aussi de la
fatigue ça n'excuse rien mais si on
essaye d'expliquer ce qui est en train
de se passer quand vous l'analyser oui
alors cette vidéo proprement dit enfin
cette interaction proprement dit je
n'étais pas donc je sais pas d'une
manière générale en tout cas ça montre
aussi que la violence elle répond à des
logiques qui sont aussi très
émotionnelles et ce genre de vidéo c'est
pour ça que Laurent Nunez a raison de
prendre les devants là-dessus de
s'excuser de façon un petit peu cachée
mais en fin de s'excuser quand même
parce que ça peut ça peut jouer dans ce
que les sociologues appellent des chocs
moraux c'est-à-dire des des images qui
choquent énormément ce qui les regardent
qui sont complètement contraires à leur
valeur et qui vont pousser à
l'engagement et on voyait les deux
petits jeunes qui étaient avant il s'est
Louis degrand on peut pas dire qu'on
soit dans les quartiers les plus
populaires de Paris et ben on voit qu'on
fait référence à ce type d'image qui qui
suscite finalement de l'empathie en tout
cas pour la victime et qui vont pousser
à l'engagement donc il faut jamais
oublier que la violence c'est elle
répond aussi à ces logiques
émotionnelles qui sont très fortes c'est
logique d'interaction avec en
l'occurrence les policiers et elle peut
générer de l'autre côté aussi de la
violence
qu'on contestataire je vais poser une
question peut-être un peu choquante mais
ce qu'elle profite à Emmanuel Macron
cette violence holocause c'est difficile
parce que
le chef de l'État dans son entretien
d'hier il s'est situé quand même sur ce
terrain qui était à la fois il est le
garant de l'intérêt général et national
il fait cette réforme ce n'est pas de
gaieté de cœur nous a-t-il dit ça le
fait pas plaisir mais il faut le faire
donc il le fait il a utilisé quand même
plusieurs fois le terme d'ordre
républicain donc on voit qu'il s'est
situé déjà dans son dans sa son rôle sa
figure de chef de l'État qui est garant
de la sécurité publique aussi il a
lourdement insisté sur l'idée que
pour lui certaines expressions de
violence se rapprocher de ce qu'on a vu
au Brésil aux États-Unis au Capitole
donc on voit qu'effectivement il est il
a il a tiré un petit peu de son
entretien voilà tu vois ton son
entretien de ce côté là moi je me suis
dit maman en l'écoutant que on avait le
sentiment de quelqu'un qui commençait
déjà aussi à
un certain nombre de mots clés ou de
notions qui parlent peut-être un
électorat qu'il faudra remobiliser un
moment donné mais effectivement on voit
qu'en faisant ça voilà on voit qu'en
faisant tout ça le thème de départ les
retraites commence progressivement à
échapper à tout le monde et on voit
qu'on parle effectivement d'autres
choses on parle du travail dans un
premier temps de qu'est-ce que c'est
qu'une rémunération juste et puis
maintenant on en vient à parler de
qu'est-ce que c'est qu'une société
démocratique et une capacité à accepter
différents points de vue et à organiser
une confrontation de point de vue de
manière pacifique et on voit que
progressivement on est effectivement sur
des considérations morales et d'attitude
politique qui parle d'autre chose que
des retraites le mouvement est en train
de se transformer c'est aussi là dessus
quoi c'est presque moins sur le la
réforme que sur les thèmes dont vous ne
parlez on va parler du la relation entre
Emmanuel Macron et les syndicats
notamment Laurent Berger dans l'instant
et peut-être sur la violence vous
vouliez intervenir Mathilde compte tenu
de l'hostilité très forte de l'opinion
vis-à-vis de cette réforme compte tenu
aussi de des réactions à son
intervention télévisée hier du chef de
l'État est-ce que finalement il y a pas
aussi un risque pour l'exécutif et pour
le président que on lui impute la
responsabilité d'une montée de violence
ou de possibles débordements c'est ça
moyen terme est-ce que ça peut lui
profiter à moyen terme mais à court
terme je pensais effectivement ça ne le
sert pas qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez-xavier alors il y a cette
question du calendrier un moyen terme
enfin à court terme ça peut ne pas lui
servir un moyen terme pourquoi pas mais
la violence c'est quand même une c'est
quand même dangereux comme ressources à
Mathieu c'est dangereux à manier pour
les protestataires c'est dangereux à
manier pour l'État les protestataires
ils doivent jamais rentrer dans un
niveau de violence qui deviendra
absolument insupportable pour l'État on
se évidemment ça sera pas le cas ici
mais à la question du terrorisme ou
d'une violence qui peut être beaucoup
plus aveugle et qui ne sera pas supporté
par le pouvoir par les pouvoirs publics
et inversement les pouvoirs publics
doivent se méfier parce que la violence
elle peut très vite leur et on a vu avec
ma découssequée dans 86 avec les
Voltigeurs qui sont pas sans rappeler
les bravesm qui sont maintenant
avec un seul qui conduit derrière ils
avaient des longues matraques
sont plus courtes mais ça fait toujours
aussi mal donc il y a toujours le risque
comme ça que la violence échappe qui est
un mort et là le pouvoir sera jugé en
effet responsable mais mais cette
question les syndicats évidemment c'est
la pause aussi Laurent Berger condamné
c'était lors de la manifestation au
début de la manifestation à Paris toutes
les violences y compris policières et il
disait jusqu'au bout il va falloir
garder l'opinion Sophie davinel donc il
a quand même intégré que le le climat de
ridicalisation ne sert pas forcément
l'intérêt bien sûr et c'est une bataille
qui se joue là et qui se joue aussi à
gauche c'est à dire que ils ont le
sentiment qu'Emmanuel Macron imagine
peut-être pouvoir profiter un petit peu
d'une violence qu'il réussirait à
dossier à manager pour affaiblir les
syndicats qui pour l'instant on la main
on va voir comment ça se termine ce soir
c'était quand même moyen l'ambiance là
avait à 17h aujourd'hui de fait et donc
on veut Emmanuel Macron profiter un
petit peu de ça pour affaiblir les
syndicats qui eux sont un peu
vont risque de vouloir laisser au
gouvernement la responsabilité des
choses donc se retirer retirer les
services d'ordre qu'on a peut-être vu un
petit peu aujourd'hui sous réserve et en
fait ce qui est intéressant c'est que
Emmanuel Macron pourrait vouloir
chercher un face-à-face avec Jean-Luc
Mélenchon qui est opposé lui à la façon
dont aux pratiques des syndicats et on
sait cette opposition entre Jean-Luc
Mélenchon qui a dénoncé la ligne Laurent
Berger Philippe Martinez Fabien Roussel
et là on sent qu'il y a quelque chose
qui change qui se transforme et on ne
sait pas au bénéfice de kiwi alors on va
parler d'un autre bras de fer tout de
suite avec vous Mathilde c'est cette
relation on va dire orageuse entre le
président et secrétaire général de la
CFDT alors l'Elysée estime que c'est le
moment d'essayer de d'apaiser le pays et
donc on peut peut-être s'interroger à ce
moment là le moment où le président
aussi cherche à ramener les syndicats à
la table des négociations il l'a dit
hier quel est l'opportunité pour le
président de s'en prendre autant à
Laurent Berger devant les Français
durant sa prise de parole sûrement un
nouveau en même temps je tends la main
et de l'autre je distribue une gifle
mais ce en même temps semble assez
contre-productif depuis le début de la
mobilisation contre la réforme des
retraites le chef de l'État avait passé
une consigne assez troupes celle de ne
surtout pas critiquer Laurent Berger et
on voit que c'est lui hier qui qui
essaye de de
critiquer le leader syndical est-ce
qu'il avait dit déjà il jugent qu'aucun
syndicat ni la CFDT ni un autre n'a
proposé de compromis c'est ça exactement
et donc on a vu à ce moment-là la
réaction immédiate de Laurent Berger
dans un tweet où il a accusé le chef de
l'État de mensonges on le voit à l'écran
et il a également tout de suite réagi
tout à l'heure pendant la manifestation
on l'écoute
on peut pas tout d'un coup ne pas avoir
eu le moindre message la moindre écoute
la moindre
audience avec le Président de la
République le premier la première
ministre du travail durant ces deux mois
et demi plus deux mois et demi
aujourd'hui
presque 3 mois et
nous qu'on nous dise bah écoutez est-ce
que vous voulez venir dans deux jours là
on va discuter d'autres sujets que les
sujets très bon c'est pas raisonnable
oui c'est vrai que dans ce contexte on a
un peu de mal à imaginer que le dialogue
social puisse reprendre venir comme si
de rien n'était pourquoi le président
cherche-t-il à énerver à ce point
Laurent Berger on a du mal à comprendre
ça peut nous rappeler un épisode au plus
fort de la crise des gilets jaunes déjà
on s'en souvient Laurent Berger avait
proposé une grande conférence sociale au
gouvernement à l'époque c'était Edouard
Philippe le Premier ministre et il lui
avait opposé une fin de non-recevoir
finalement en essayant voilà de
critiquer Laurent Berger qui est
pourtant l'une des figures de cette
contestation et qui pour l'instant est à
peu près irréprochable puisqu'il
condamne toute violence il a une
attitude
très responsable pour voilà comme leader
syndical finalement ça contribue à à
victimiser Laurent Berger et à nourrir
le récit d'un pouvoir qui serait sourd
jupitérien enfermé dans ces certitudes
donc c'est plus fort qui est manuel
Macron finalement c'est comme si son
tempérament de bagarreur reprenait le
dessus dans des moments comme ça de de
crise très intense parce qu'on rappelle
que pour le président que ce soit
Laurent Berger ou d'autres leaders
syndicaux ces fameux corps
intermédiaires le président considère
qu'il ne représente que même
Bruno cotreesse c'est il faut entendre
tout ce qu'a dit Laurent Berger il y a
quand même il a pas totalement fermé la
porte il a dit on viendra peut-être
autour de la table mais là on va poser
nos on va poser nos conditions ça c'est
un moment important de la journée aussi
oui d'autant que ça n'est pas dans les
habitudes de leur berger de fermer les
portes au contraire lui il a toujours
depuis le début de la crise il a
toujours expliqué que il était ouvert
discuté qui souhaitait discuter il est
sorti de nombreuses fois de réunions à
Matignon en disant c'est assis on a
écouté poliment mais on n'a pas été
entendu et donc lui effectivement il est
plutôt sur cette sur cette idée de dire
mais mais ça n'est pas nous les qui
bloquons les discussions je remarque que
dans l'entretien d'Emmanuel Macron hier
quelques secondes avant qu'il ne disent
il n'y a pas eu de proposition de
compromis de la part des syndicats et la
même essayé un peu de déstabiliser
Laurent Berger en disant mais Laurent
Berger il est venu devant son
organisation politique son organisme
syndicale il a proposé d'augmenter la
durée de cotisations il n'a pas été
suivi donc même le mettant un peu en
porte-à-faux de ce point de ce point de
vue là et donc je trouvais que là on va
envoyer effectivement une sorte de de
relation très compliqué entre le chef de
l'État et le patron de la et le patron
de la de la de la CFDT alors expliqué ça
c'est la difficulté structurelle qui
Emmanuel Macron avec les corps
intermédiaires les représentant de la
société civile depuis le début de son
premier de son premier mandat je pense
pas ailleurs que
l'engagement de lamberger dans
dans l'action contre cette réforme des
retraites et sans aucun doute un des
éléments les plus structurants et les
plus essentiels de ce qui c'est de ce
qui s'est tramé il faut appeler que le
10 janvier lorsqu'ils le projet c'est
Laurent Berger qui prend la parole au
titre de l'Inter syndical et c'est lui
qu'il y a un communiqué déjà assez
offensif et donc la présence de
lamberger au premier plan de
l'opposition à sans doute jouer un rôle
absolument essentiel je reviens à la
radicalisation Sophie davinel est-ce que
ça peut
fissurer la solidité de l'Inter
syndicale
c'est compliqué à savoir pour l'instant
parce que je pense que ils sont tous
attachés
d'une certaine façon
au moins les directions des grandes
confédérations attachées à ce que ça
cette à ce que ça ne déborde pas pour
les raisons que nous avons donné tout à
l'heure c'est-à-dire que le une forme de
chaos pourrait profiter au chef de
l'État et il ne le souhaite évidemment
pas donc pour cette raison là après
jusqu'à quel point les directions des
grandes centrales vont maintenir
localement
les les troupes j'oserais dire on a vu
comment ça s'est passé à Fos-sur-Mer on
a vu et pourtant à Fos-sur-Mer nous ne
sommes pas avec des jeunes parisiens
excités avec les lignes noires des
totaux qui vont sur les facultés ce sont
vraiment c'est le monde des travailleurs
donc le monde ouvrier celui des
syndicats et là on sent que de la base
ça commence à monter il y a quand même
une question moi qui qui m'est venue en
cette fin d'après-midi en voyant la
manifestation à Paris c'est ce sont les
Black Blocs on les avait pas vu depuis
deux mois là nos confrères de BFM TV en
comptait un millier comment comment une
question toute bête pourquoi ils sont là
ce soir ils étaient pas là les
précédents alors
d'abord les Black Blocs c'est pas c'est
pas un groupe qui apparaît ou qui
disparaît ce qu'on appelle Black Bloc
c'est une tactique c'est une technique
finalement d'occupation un peu violente
de la rue à l'origine c'était un
mouvement qui venait des autonomies
italiens des des huricois en particulier
des milieux autonomes zurichois et qui
s'est diffusé en particulier avec des
grandes manifestations altermondialistes
à peu près partout en Europe et même
d'ailleurs en Amérique du Nord donc là
c'est des contestataires souvent
appartenant à l'ultra gauche en fait je
pense à deux mouvances particulières
l'ultra gauche et ce qu'on a pu appeler
les Ultra jaunes c'est-à-dire des gilets
jaunes un peu radicalisés qui reviennent
un petit peu dans le mouvement et qui
utilise cette tactique Black Bloc c'est
à dire des tactiques de violence de rue
de confrontation avec tes forces de
l'ordre et comme il le disent eux-mêmes
je reprends leur vocabulaire de
libération des zones autonomes
temporaires c'est-à-dire ils essayent de
libérer des zones dans l'espace public
de l'empreinte de l'État et de
l'empreinte du capitalisme concrètement
ça veut dire taper du flic ou donner des
banques ou taper des enseignes des
grandes enseignes commerciales etc
c'était important de redonner
l'explication merci beaucoup et je
repose la question pourquoi sont-ils là
ce soir alors ils sont là parce que les
Black Blocs vous savez ils interviennent
là où ça s'agit et je pense qu'ils
avaient vu tout comme nous tous autour
de ce plateau que ça allait être une
journée agitée donc ils sont venus faut
voir les blagues alors que précédemment
et quoi ils craignaient les le service
d'ordre des syndicats enfin vous voyez
je cherche
avec les services
il y a eu des affrontements très forts
avec les services d'or des syndicats les
syndics les services d'or de syndicats
et en particulier celui de la CGT qui a
un des plus professionnels qui soit
supporte pas les Black Blocs c'est aussi
la violence des Black Blocs c'est aussi
une façon de de marginaliser
contestataire que sont les de
s'approprier un mouvement parce que on
sait comment fonctionne les les médias
souvent ce qui est ce qui ressort sont
les images de violence et donc
finalement on parle plus des Black Blocs
nous on a évidemment on cherche pas le
faire mais que du du coeur de la
manifestation c'est véritable donc voilà
est-ce que vous êtes posé cette question
aussi aujourd'hui et c'est ce que
j'essayais de de glisser tout à l'heure
mais il faudra le vérifier je pense
qu'on est encore trop frais mais je me
pose
moi la résidence n'ont pas été un tout
petit peu plus mous que d'habitude pour
bloquer justement ces ces ces tensions
c'est pas forcément volontairement mais
je pense qu'il y a un ras-le-bol de chez
tout le monde et que à un moment il se
disent bon bah après tout peut-être que
je ne sais pas peut-être qu'il faut
peut-être pas la violence se dire
ensuite effectivement il y a un effet
d'aubaine très justement il se disent
que cette fois-ci on est vraiment dans
un état d'esprit de de voilà on est plus
dans la période législative celle du
Parlement on est sorti de ça évidemment
on attend tous la réponse du Conseil
constitutionnel mais je pense que la
majorité des Français ne sont pas très
sensibles à cet argument du rythme même
si ça peut venir le référendum
d'initiative partagée qui est une autre
façon de sortir de la crise de façon
institutionnelle et que là on laisse un
peu la rue parler et c'est peut-être
aussi du côté des syndicats l'envie de
dire à l'état regardez regardez de quoi
vous pourriez être responsable et c'est
le sens du dialogue effectivement
être Laurent Berger même Philippe
Martinez et le chef de l'État que de
dire regardez ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui regardez ce qui se passe si
nous ne sommes plus là regardez ce dont
vous allez être responsable et ce que
vous allez aller devoir gérer alors dans
cette équation il y a la jeunesse qui
évidemment joue un rôle important depuis
quelques jours je vous propose
d'entendre sur ce thème la réaction
c'était là aussi dans la manifestation à
Paris de la présidente de lunès Holman
ou elle age
Macron et
à son que les commençons mobilisés
contre la réforme des retraites qu'à la
boue était d'avoir été soi-disant voté
on ira jusqu'au bout pour le retrait et
qu'on ira en fait jusqu'au bout pour
notre avenir parce qu'aujourd'hui c'est
pas juste la réforme des retraites c'est
un ras-le-bol généralisé de la jeunesse
qui en a marre en fait de vivre dans la
précarité qu'il y en a marre de ne pas
pouvoir rêver un avenir et qui
aujourd'hui veut pas bâtir le monde de
demain
Bruno 13 pourquoi les pourquoi les
jeunes sont on a encore un peu de mal à
l'évaluer mais il y avait quand même des
blocages dans dans 140-150 lycées
aujourd'hui dans les universités ce
qu'on ne voyait pas là aussi lors des
lors des journées de mobilisation
précédente voilà c'est là aussi le
mouvement est en train de changer de de
forme et peut-être de conséquences
politiques pour pour Emmanuel Macron
comment vous l'analysez sans doute
effectivement le 49-3 le sentiment que
ça ne répond pas à des
notions des aspirations importantes chez
les chez les jeunes qui sont en train au
fond de découvrir l'univers de la
politique que la vie citoyenne d'adulte
et que ça ne répond pas à que le système
ne répond pas au fond un certain nombre
de grandes valeurs un système qui écoute
un système qui est démocratique et c'est
vrai que de ce point de vue là
l'utilisation du 49-3 est considérée
comme un véritable déni de démocratie
quelque chose qui ne respecte pas le
contrat de base qui est le pouvoir de
discuter avec le peuple on revient à la
violence institutionnelle
et par ailleurs même s'il faut toujours
nuancer que la jeunesse c'est en fait un
concept général il est traversé il y a
différentes formes de jeunesse qui est
déjà au travail en une quais dans les
universités mais on voit dans toutes les
données d'enquête on voit que les jeunes
si on prend par exemple les 18 24 ans
considèrent davantage que manifester ou
se mettre en grève est un moyen
privilégié d'expression publique que
voter
on l'a encore testé récemment dans notre
enquête sur la confiance politique
sur l'ensemble des Français on a un peu
plus de la moitié des personnes
interrogées qui disent que voter c'est
le meilleur moyen d'expression publique
chez les 18 24 ans on tombe à 38%
la manif par contre 39 je dirais
l'action collective et même la violence
d'une certaine façon c'est fun hein donc
il faut jamais oublier ça je veux dire
la violence on la voit toujours et à
juste titre comme quelque chose de mal
de pas bien mais ça peut être aussi une
vraie poussée d'adrénaline il suffit de
voir les images des Black Ops moi
j'apprends les gilets jaunes j'avais
suivi beaucoup de manifs de blabloc de
voir les images des Black Blocs face au
CRS il y a une part de jeu il y a une
part de plaisir finalement dans l'usage
de l'avion c'est l'adrénaline une charge
de CRS c'est quand même une certaine
donnée un sens politique c'est ce que
vous êtes en train de nous dire mais
c'est pas c'est pas antilope
l'action collective c'est aussi une
formation à la citoyenneté et c'est
aussi pour ça que ça attire beaucoup de
jeunes dans les lycées ou ailleurs il y
a un dernier petit chapitre qu'on va
ouvrir tout de suite dans ce débat c'est
la nouvelle donne législative
je propose un terme traduit de nombreux
rejoindre bonsoir Tam elle a été
annoncée par le chef de l'Etat hier dans
son dans son interview avec une réforme
des retraites qui a déjà fait une
victime collatérale c'est la loi sur
l'immigration et oui voilà une violence
inquiète au projet de loi immigration ce
texte qui devait être des battu la
semaine prochaine au Sénat et bien voilà
il passe à la trappe on l'a appris mardi
déjà journée de consultation d'Emmanuel
Macron lors de laquelle il s'est
entretenu avec Gérard Larcher le
président du Sénat qui a demandé dès le
week-end dernier au président de la
République le report du texte et il a
expliqué pourquoi ce matin à nos
confrères LCI écoutez je prends mes
responsabilités c'est moi qui ai évoqué
dimanche soir avec le président de la
République la nécessité qu'un texte
aussi important
devait être examiné dans des conditions
apaisées et les conditions d'apaisement
ne sont pas là il faut dire aussi que
tout cela et bien c'était la chronique
d'un report voire d'une mort annoncée
pour ce texte un dès la semaine dernière
en off des députés de la majorité
présidentielle nous expliquait déjà
qu'il pensait qu'elle quand tel texte ne
pouvait pas obtenir de majorité à
l'Assemblée qu'il ne serait jamais
inscrit tel quel à l'ordre du jour alors
quelle difficulté potentielle poser ce
texte qui était à la fois plus répressif
que la situation actuelle par exemple
pour expulser plus facilement les
délinquants étrangers et puis il y avait
un volet qui facilitait au contraire
l'obtention d'un titre de séjour pour
les étrangers occupant un métier en
tension c'est ce que Gérald Darmanin
avait résumé avec une formule destinée à
être comprise par les enfants de
maternelle être gentil avec les gentils
être méchants avec les méchants bref
super en même temps pour essayer de
contenter et la droite et la gauche et
qui avait abouti aux résultats
diamétralement opposés puisqu'il ne
contentait personne les uns dénonçant un
appel d'air pour l'immigration et les
autres une loi qui déroulait le tapis
rouge à l'extrême droite bref on ne peut
pas plaire à tout le monde alors toute
réforme de l'immigration et de
l'intégration n'a pas pour autant été
abandonné qui a décidé le gouvernement
et donc vous l'avez dit il a décidé le
gouvernement de saucissonner le texte
diviser le projet de loi en petit bout
pour essayer d'obtenir une majorité
texte par texte voir mesures par mesure
le gouvernement voudrait un projet de
loi plus consensuel que le texte actuel
suivi de plusieurs propositions de loi
donc d'initiatives parlementaires mais
sur lequel bien sûr il aurait un oeil
plus que vigilant or cette méthode pour
la droite sénatoriale c'est déjà niet
n'aurait pas un texte mais il y aurait
sans doute trois textes c'est à dire que
pour la loi de régularisation notamment
l'article 3 qui crée un titre de séjour
de régularisation sur les métiers en
tension un formidable appel d'air là
j'imagine qu'ils vont aller rechercher
l'appui de gauche à l'Assemblée
nationale et puis pour un Cerdon de
procédure un peu plus contraignant la
pluie à droite mais ça peut pas marcher
comme ça il n'y aura pas notre soutien
ni nous ni à l'Assemblée nationale en
réalité sur ce genre de texte à la
découpe donc vous entendez l'opposition
de Bruno Retailleau le patron de la
droite sénatoriale qui englobait hier
dans sa position ses collègues députés
ce matin Gérard Larcher était sur la
même ligne il a même précisé que le
gouvernement n'avait pas demandé au
parlementaire de déposer des
propositions de loi pour l'arranger sauf
que écouter ce matin et bien le
président du groupe des députés et l'air
à l'Assemblée nationale Olivier marralex
sur publicex
on a pas d'un petit texte donc je pense
on va on va remettre nous sur la table
très rapidement avec Éric fiotti une
proposition de loi sur sur des questions
sur les questions migratoires
on a déjà on en a fait plusieurs on a
toutes les solutions on va déposer
totalement et de blocage c'est vraiment
on parle de blocage depuis le début de
cette émission dans la rue mais c'est un
blocage parlementaire aussi et donc on
ne voit pas bien et un blocage qui est
dû en partie comme la très bien dit
notre concert au fait que à droite au
sein même des LR donc ils sont dans une
situation de semis implosion et donc on
ne voit pas bien et c'est pour ça que à
Bruno cotresse parlait très justement de
de ce parfum entendu hier pendant
l'interview du chef de l'État de de
d'élection et c'est évidemment un parfum
de législative la seule chose c'est
est-ce que là aussi il y aurait un
risque une odeur de poudre qui qui
viendrait monter des urnes et qui
évidemment est ce sujet tant de fois là
aussi rebattu de ce que le rassemblement
national pourrait tirer comme profit
d'une telle élection on voit mal comment
effectivement Emmanuel Macron va se
sortir de ses quatre années qui viennent
et je suis très curieuse on est tous
curieux en tout cas la première
tentative de de d'explication de prise
de parole on va dire que il y a pas eu
de grands de de grandes nouveautés on se
disait est-ce qu'il va sortir quelque
chose de son chapeau ça a été non la
réponse merci beaucoup c'était
passionnant ce débat avec vous je
rappelle votre livre Xavier chrétier que
vous avez écrit avec Nathalie du Clos
consacré à ce thème des violences
politiques et publiées aux éditions
Armand Colin